here we go
15 seconds until kickoff war zone kings
one minute war zone rated 58 players
1855 average rating
time handicapped 30 minute tournament
experience level 13 er excuse me 30
required
here we go
let's roll here double those points
alrighty
you can do it warzone kings oh what a
start
let us start
i have that on pre-move let me do some
homework
this guy entered and he's known to
frying me
oh we got action we got action
all right
all right
let's go
all right it's not uh
it's not dragging like it was uh last
time at the start
take like that
you gotta watch out for the pre-moves
okay let's establish a pawn here and get
my bishop right there
kick the knight and push here otherwise
the knight jumps there first let's kick
that queen away and then pawn push a
couple times or no let me get more
development in hang on
hang on we gotta watch out for these
now let's castle
and now maybe
maybe what let's push a couple times i'm
gonna take that knight
get that knight out of there
i'm gonna have a bunch of exchanges
i gotta do this this is very awkward
very awkward i shouldn't have allowed
this
night right here coming up
more trades
more trades i'm on this once
check and then what
another check
got this time time time time
king is a fighter
sneaky
sneakiness
i don't have any time though
no time
back to tournament two somebody has four
four and a bunch of twos all righty
uh oh uh oh c4 it's the c4 player
all right i'm on f7
watch out for my f2
i sneak over here
queen h4 my bishop's gonna get kicked
around
f5 coming up okay let's do this
and so
around that i'm still gonna go with this
i have a queen trade very soon
uh like right now very soon
pawn takes or bishop takes okay i'm back
here
now the rook
i'm try and open this up over here
and maybe target that pawn if the rook
goes too far away or even this one
actually yeah i'm gonna go after that
one
i think i have that pawn at least
uh we're gonna see about that though
my rook wants activity stay very active
right here this is the next pawn
to target although this bishop is way
too strong i need to get rid of it
even if i have ugly ponds over here
i have this pawn right here actually
there's a bunch of stuff that's falling
and then a check
right here to grab more stuff
more pawns
and then get my king position going
king position
king position king position king
position
on that pawn
king position next why am i not going
with the king position
time is okay
time should be quite all right i'm going
to take that now my rook's defending
then push and then push again with check
let's do this first so i push and the
king can't go here
and now
i think okay now i have this
just going to take that bishop with
check
and then give a check here push a couple
more times it might be me it's close to
me
very close to me
and then this time situation where are
we at
that's me
back to tournament that was a big win
strong player 12 10 7 6
25 minutes remaining still a lot of time
panthers
panthers is here
um
okay
is this going to start up
let's go
i'm dropping back 13 is up there
all right
um
18 is up there oh man
how many points would i get for this two
or four
20 points is up there
wow
i'm nowhere near confetti land i'm
dropping back seventh
let's go to another game
what games are going on
right here let's see this game
nothing in my game
what's going on
here okay black is going to be winning
that one though and
extending that
score
nothing here still
this is too much time to be waiting
this guy is 20 how is he doing come on
black
okay hey hey hey we got uh action
we have action hey hey
all right carol khan i should have
avoided i always say i want the fantasy
variation
the fantasy variation is better
oh that's not right
oh no no it is that's that's the right
move order i thought it was the the pawn
pushed before like the night played here
or something
and i think this is a line too instead
of going with h5 i think having this
pawn here
is a line maybe i could get like a g5
push in now that there's some support
um
oh i should have moved my king first
bishop f4 i think is pretty good
i'd like to avoid oh hang on pawn push
i'm going to sack that
i want to open some files can i get that
h file
um
or
h2h2h2
right here and then queen h4 swinging
over that knight is hit twice i get the
knight at least or no pawn push could be
played the queen guards of the night
laterally
it's not played though
let's open this up and then maybe
do what
oh there's gonna be queen check and my
knight is dead
ah
it's not dead though i'm on the queen
i should have checked here might as well
just done that i wanted to control this
somehow
um
can i give a check i can't do that now
oh right here right here i got to watch
out my rook is hanging
and h8 is covered
just give a check
just come back here i want to defend
everything
defend everything
is the plan
queen trade
10 seconds remaining
i could pre-move that bishop's in a pin
okay and now
forks forks i want the rook seven
seconds remaining
ah
can't move
pawns
pawns pawns pawns
check another pawn move the clock back
to tournament i only have 15 what's my
score i only have 15 what's what's this
game get this out of here i have so many
tabs opened up oh no
i have so many tabs opened up i have to
close them
and try and close them
close that one click
okay i don't have any more tabs open i
can't i don't even know where i'm at the
leaders
it's it's only shown like i have 15.
unless i have to refresh or something
that knight's dead quick resigner
my computer is going
berserk right now
yeah it's a quick resigner where are we
at well not a quick resigner but
23 42 is up oh no watch over f2 i'm
gonna cover f2 right now there you got
nothing on my f2
the e3 defense you will not have any f2
i'm scaring that point
right away
right away you will have no f2
no oh no no no okay everything's okay
just secure f2
everything's gonna be okay hopefully
give me that light square bishop get on
the light squares now that they're
weakened
weak light squares
uh i'm biting on a rock
is this going to be hit it might be
it might be uh oh
give me that rook
give me that rook
jump in here why is my queen not playing
here could somebody tell me why is she
not on this diagonal sooner right here i
chop here a couple times
positions opening up
it's opening up
let's just go here
just go here
whoa don't you dare
there was f2 and there might have been a
fork and there is a fork oh no
no no no
no no no no
man
i got the queen
h2
h2 was gonna be killed if i didn't play
g3
watch out watch out don't be silly
why did i even move my knight there what
is it doing uh oh
check is the rook gonna play here 14
seconds
queen f4
let's just do that i want to open up the
diagonal
check
and then right here nasty discovery
checks
get out of there rook
okay i have this
sneaky
sneakiness
that's mate that's me back to tournament
that's important 64 way legs slow down
42 40
spazz
1988
okay
okay
all righty
tempo gainer and then pawn push
queen gonna give a check no i have a
good center
pressure being placed on it okay i don't
have to worry about bishop there
to g4
or g5 pinning my knight
h2
under fire queenside castle
the knight has to move i have h2
queenside castle not i'm opposite the
queen
um let me take with the pawn so i could
take on h2
h2 and then push this pawn
push one time and another time and then
maybe sack or something i'm gonna do
this i think
just pawn
our bishop right here and let it take i
want to get the h file opened up
let's try that
i'm going to take the bait
no
watch out for forks tricky nights tricky
nights
pins
watch out for the pins
pawn push next i want that h file to
open up
okay it's opened up by force now
give a check this has to be leading to
mate very soon doesn't it
where's that mate
where is that mate mate in one threat
time situation i'm gonna do that that's
me back to tournament 45 82 slow down 9
out of 9.
wow
crazy town
crazy town
get the queens off
okay this is uh some gambit huh
this is definitely some gambit
we're gonna have the queens off the
board i'm up a pond
i'm up a pond right
does this matter it matters
it matters i'm up upon i don't see that
there's compensation
is there compensation
castle and then
uh
go here queen king to f1
gets out of pins on the g file as well
what am i missing i get that bishop 46
seconds
you get the bishop pair i might take
that
maybe i could kick that bishop around
okay i got that dark square bishop
what's that even do
what's that move even do
watch out sneaky moves
right here pawn push i should have done
pawn push sooner
ah stopping that night let's trade a bit
25
gonna trade
okay let's get this majority going
upon majority
pawns on light squares
the knight is kind of boxed out he's
still boxed out
he's still boxed out restraint
king position pawn push
get this pawn going
maintain that pawn
give a check maybe one day i should have
taken and then um
i should have done something else pawn
push a couple times it's going to be
past g pawn
difficult to track
down okay
what did they do they resigned oh they
missed up with their king
92-71
fearless this guy is fearless
this guy is fearless right here
okay 15 minutes and change
let's do that i want to get an e5 maybe
e5
and then e4 i need more support for that
i should have just taken the pawn take
free pawns that was a free pawn
ah
that was a free pun i got i'm taking my
bishop otherwise there's some tactics to
get my knight if i take like this f4
uh oh
now hold this if pawn push b4
and do some weakness maybe i'll just
take and then take here
i'd like to get queen up okay this is
good now there's no b4 this looks
awkward for the rook to be here
oh i
see all right let's just do that so my
queen doesn't have to babysit pawn push
get my knight
doing what maybe rook to b8 i should
have played
all right i'm gonna do this bishop takes
i squash the bishop i think i should
have captured like that that was silly
pawn put no it's maybe still available
pawn push a couple times
and then the bishop is kind of crunched
crunch the bishop and then get my bishop
right here exchange after r square
bishops there's probably knight to f4
i got to stop knight f5
clock situation is what
sneakiness here
have to watch out for that tricky knight
i'm just going to take that
i don't want to keep sweating
uh about that knight f4 move so keep
this structure right here and then uh
the bishop is dead
over here why'd i do that i should get
my knight to g5 i want to make this pawn
move
it's going to move soon
all right let's go over here now it's a
locked position knights do well here
oh it's going to be smashed open i could
feel it it's going to happen soon
no time
anything
no time forks i could take the bishop
with check
okay right here anything
that's been there for a while i think
back to tournament 75 112 87
75.75
oh no
oh no this guy
this guy again
ah tough games
tough games i tell you
let me get that knight
okay this is a good
i feel like this is a good structure
here that can't be right
that can't be right can it
i'm on this pond twice i work myself
into a pin
this is a good position though isn't it
bishop here
why'd i do that
how do i get developed
how do i get developed
i could take that pawn maybe my knight
needs to do something else
oh take that pawn
with the knight with tempo
um come back and hit the queen
i might have to castle
yeah i'm gonna castle
my knight is hanging in some variations
let's get this over here
get that pawn going he's a past pawn
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa knight here
would have been a killer
i have to get rid of that i think
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
why'd i do that
this is very scary i have to block with
my bishop
i don't have anything oh does this work
i only have 11 seconds
i got to do this
is there time to save this somehow
clock
my opponent goes so fast
six seconds remaining can i just get
this pawn rolling keep going
clock situation
i can't move
well i can't i can't move
i can't breathe
i can't breathe
oh he's down on time
oh man
oh whale egg oh man the pack leader
right when i can't breathe and my heart
is racing
oh
my goodness
he knows what's coming
he knows it's coming
that night going to be taken
yeah he would be taken next wow
wow
get these light square bishops off
um
oh this is dangerous
it's dangerous it's very dangerous 39
seconds
what's that move i don't understand that
i don't understand that move
there's no maybe it was the wrong
i don't know what that was
i don't know there's compensation here
my night is dead isn't it
yeah it is
oh there's the compensation
oh just let him die for free
don't even get anything no compensation
for that night just let him die like
that right that was wonderful
yeah going the same direction as that
bishop
get out of there rook
get out of there rook
can i get that night would that night
please just move
oh man i'm on the queen
oh
oh oh i don't have any time
clock clock clock clock clock
i gotta do this i gotta pre-move some
stuff
that's gonna be taken
i gotta hit that night
the knight has to take i gotta get here
12 seconds
right here can i get that knight
leave me alone leave me alone leave me
alone man
give me that night
can i give a
check
checks i need to get time burners
oh oh hang on
3.5 this is important
i got it
my goodness can i get a like a clean win
without having to hold my breath 150 123
that was a leader
man eight minutes and change this is so
intense
ah
this is so intense
i have so many people to try and get
back like ah
there's so many people up there in the
lead
why are they in the lead
why are they there and i'm not
i gotta shut the door on the bishop give
me this pun gimme
it's committal but i'm gonna try it
get the queens off
and then get that pawn very quick
very quick i need to get that pawn
oh man
i gotta oh man i don't well
rook take no i thought there might be a
fork or something i gotta get rid of
that bishop okay i got rid of the bishop
now let's get rid of a rook
okay this is
sad
get my majority going i want to get my
king to f3 if allowed it's not allowed
stop that bishop from having fun get out
of there get my majority going
right here
kill the bishop and then put pressure on
the palm like this
16 seconds where's my time
where is my time here
king position
king position where are you at king
position
night
position pawn push
we're gonna have a trade no he's a past
pawn now
past pawn
they're gonna be a check
on the rook
ah why'd i do that i never rook trade
pawn push
let me try it there's a check
um
right here
i have that
pawn push a couple times
mate in a couple
pawn push one two why are these down to
the wire why can't i have more than
three seconds remaining when i win
oh man
i guess it's okay
because i'm still winning games but
they're so tough
man
knight c6
can i get a quick win with more than
three seconds remaining
i want to get a win with more than three
seconds remaining
oh
all right
let's guard that
light squares just take that knight
i would have uh gotten a pawn there
and now
oh
this is dangerous now very dangerous
where's that mate
deadly discovery deadly discovery checks
you could be making two
ah
meeting uh it's not really happening
it feels right right there to just get
uh
something on the light squares
i have the queen
mate in two close to it
one that's mate no they resigned back to
term at 170 155 153 five minutes and
change
uh
i can maybe get two i could definitely
get two more games in
two more games are needed
okay
oh oh i shouldn't have pre-moved that
can i get something sneaky sneakiness
sneakiness
no
no sneakiness allowed
um bishop f4
all right that's
can i gotta get rid of that queen in
order to make progress
get out of there queen
get out
all right we're gonna have a queen trade
aren't we
we are
okay i have a dark square bishop i have
the bishop pair
these the bishops are guarding all entry
points over here on this file
pawn push bishop here
probably a bit annoying and then push a
little bit
g5
open up the position a little bit
bishop f4 h6
let's capture like that i don't want to
open that file up
king here probably a good home
push and then take a couple times
let's hit that oh yeah this is a
wonderful file right there everybody
wanted to go on the g file or the c the
b file
i don't know what i'm saying
what is this rook doing can i get this
pawn 19 they have 19 seconds
okay is this going to be a domino effect
right here pawn push
yes stay active bishop
stay active bishop
um let's take this
to get rid of that night
um
clock clock clock clock
no quick wins around
a lot of resistance
less than two seconds anything back to
tournament 173
255
wow
that is insane
255 points
crazy
crazy i'm not i'm not being that i'm
struggling to get third place
we're struggling for third place can we
have a third place please
okay
check
might get a smothered mate
has to be taken
has to take it otherwise it's a mate
one two three
if the king moves it's a mate in three
one two smothered me be aware of this
combination tactics
tactics
just move come on
you know you want to move
oh no
oh
no okay here we go here we go
can i get a second
255 210
210
e4
e4
all right all right we're gonna have
this again or
yeah oh that's very weakening
it's very weakening
all right
messed up structure
potentially all right i'm doing this so
i could target e6
and also kick that bishop away
uh i could take it right now but i'm not
going to rather have my knight there
all right
with check
and then
get that guy out of there so i could
play to e1
take this pawn i'm going to do that
remove support points of the knight
the knight might move the rook is
hitting my bishop i think i just back up
maybe move my queen
to defend it i like maybe backing up to
c2 so i could play queen d3 and maybe
have a mate
dark square weaknesses
like to maybe get my bishop on this
diagonal i'm gonna take my knight
pawn push
um
bishop h6
bishop h6
it's a good it's a good home
and now get my knight right in here
maybe even pinned this knight let's jump
in there
capture with this pawn
tempo
any tempo on that knight queen d4 pawn
push
i'm on this night
something needs to be done there might
be some tricky stuff there let's get rid
of this remove the defender of f6
i take like that i recapture i'm winning
a piece i'm pretty sure because i could
take this knight with check knight b4 is
hitting the bishop but again with check
less than five seconds remaining
oh i could do that this game is not
going to end
anything anything back to tournament
back to tournament 213 i have a lead of
or no i only have a second place what is
it oh there's no way there's no way
there's only 30 seconds remaining i
might not get confetti
oh come on come on come on come on come
on
oh sneakiness
sneakiness
everywhere there is sneakiness just call
it blow the whistle on this tournament
oh oh oh oh oh hang on
hang on hang on hang on please just call
it give me the confetti please
come on what did i get yes give me some
confetti
oh man
i'm exhausted
ah to backers
sort of
tough
ah man
back to back thirds
ah man
253 230 213 and not far off were these
two guys no one two three four
any one of these three
if they would have won
guess who would have been in
non-confetti land